hello everyone a potential disaster has
been averted at europe's largest nuclear
power plant in just the past few hours
ukraine's foreign minister as well as an
official at the zapatis facility in the
southeast say there has been a fire
after it came under attack from russian
forces russia now controls the site
after heavy shelling in the early hours
of friday
the latest details in this report from
leah harding
a firefight at europe's biggest nuclear
power plant
and a fire that burns for more than an
hour before firefighters can put it out
as a result of strikes there is a fire
at the nuclear power plant i repeat as a
result of strikes by russian federation
forces on the nuclear power plant a fire
has erupted
the town mayor pleading for the fighting
to stop
i ask you to come to your senses and
immediately stop firing at the nuclear
power plant
ukraine's president issues a dire
warning of the consequences of the
attack
if there is an explosion that's the end
for everyone the end for europe the
evacuation of europe only urgent action
by europe can stop the russian troops
did not allow the death of europe from a
catastrophe at a nuclear power station
firefighters were eventually granted
access to the site and put the fire out
taking out a reactor's grid connection
in and of itself won't lead to an
accident
but it is the removal of one layer of
defense for the plant and in a war
situation there is a concerningly high
chance that those other layers of
defense will be stripped away as well
the nuclear facility's six reactors are
located near the town of energodar
an area contested by the russian
military and its separatist allies
the nuclear plant has been the site of
defiant resistance by ordinary
ukrainians using themselves as human
shields to keep russian troops away
the reality of a nuclear disaster is all
too real to these people in 1986 the
chernobyl nuclear plant exploded
thousands of people dying of the
consequences of radiation and leaving a
huge area of the country uninhabitable
to this day
it is one of only two nuclear energy
accidents rated at the maximum severity
the other being the 2011 fukushima
disaster in japan
we're very relieved and i think possibly
you know what japan has spent a lot of
time doing over the last couple of years
has been to put in
anti-terrorism renovations at the
various nuclear sites around japan so
perhaps that's what's protected ukraine
in this instance as well
the fire may be out
but the war around it rages on
leah harding al jazeera
okay here's natasha butler in la viv now
near the border with
poland this is quite something isn't it
you know that strategic areas are going
to be targeted in a war but a nuclear
power plant like goodness
yeah i mean extremely worrying indeed
and we
have learned uh recently in the past few
moments that it seems that russian
troops have seized control of that
nuclear power plant that comes from
regional authorities regional ukrainian
authorities we're still trying to get
more details on exactly what that means
and whether or not it is
confirmed but a very tense and difficult
night ukrainian authorities are saying
that the power plant has been secured
now but only after many hours in which a
fire was burning in that plant after it
was attacked by russian forces ukrainian
firefighters were not able to get
anywhere close to it at the beginning to
put out the blaze because they were
being fired upon by russian troops
that's what ukrainian officials say they
did finally though managed to extinguish
uh the blaze but only after some time we
understand that a generating unit had
been hit inside the plant but as i said
the the site now now uh apparently safe
apparently secure but condemnation
really from many world leaders joe biden
boris johnson uh but also of course
vladimir sinsky saying that russia was
now using nuclear terror that it was
threatening not just ukraine of course
but also the whole of europe ukraine's
foreign minister dimitro coleba saying
that a radiation league from this plant
europe's largest could be 10 times worse
than chernobyl
gosh
natasha i know it's a a large conflict
with a lot of things happening but can
you sort of run us through some of the
other developments from
other places in the country mario paul
for example
yeah another of course very frightening
very difficult night for people across
ukraine particularly in these areas
where fighting has intensified in the
east and the south and the south uh you
mentioned that port of mario paul it is
a key strategic port it is located on
the sea of as often residents and
authorities are saying it is now a city
under siege with constant russian
shelling they are saying that water
heating electricity supplies have all
been cut it is the winter here it is
extremely cold and you can only imagine
that is going to be an incredibly
difficult situation for the people there
as they are huddled in basement in the
most
appalling conditions in the city of
kirsan another strategic port not far
from crimea on the black sea
that poll was seized by russian troops
on thursday but we also understand from
authorities there that they are talking
about three days left of medical
supplies the same in places like kharkiv
under constant shelling it is a
humanitarian disaster unfolding we
understand that humanitarian corridors
could be put in place by ukrainian
and after ukrainian and russian
negotiators agreed on that on thursday
but when that will happen well obviously
for the people on the ground not soon
enough yeah of course thank you natasha
butler with the update from levive
russia and ukraine making some hints
that there is some progress in the talks
both sides at least agreeing on the need
for humanitarian corridors
uh there's natasha saying they're no
indication on when they would be
established to help civilians escape the
war the delegations met in belarus for
talks aimed at stopping the fighting
but even as the negotiators met russian
forces continue to target major
ukrainian cities thousands
are thought to have either been killed
or wounded since russia invaded more
than a week ago here's jonah hull with
the other developments
major ukrainian cities are surrounded
and under constant attack
this is cernev a city of textile
factories churches and monasteries its
greatest misfortune to lie on the root
of russia's advance from the north
in the eastern city of kharkiv too
people wake daily to scenes of terrible
destruction and a fast rising civilian
death toll
look what pudding is doing
this is a war crime committed against
the civilians against
the city of kharkiv
this city of one and a half million
people most ethnic russians is being
torn apart by russian forces for no
reason other than that it exists just
across the border from russia
in ukraine
and in the far south ukraine's biggest
port odessa is under threat too
[Applause]
here frantic efforts have been underway
for days to build defenses against a
possible beach landing
multiple vessels belonging to russia's
black sea fleet hover on the horizon
including landing ships and support
craft
ukraine's military is very much still in
this fight reinforced by supplies of
weapons from abroad
they've been able to apply real pressure
to the russian advance slowing the
progress of a vast column of armor
artillery and soldiers heading for the
capital kiev
along its route once sleepy commuter
towns lie in ruins a foretaste of what
may be in store for kiev the apparent
aim to encircle the city and besiege it
from his bunker under heavy guard
president vladimir zelensky wages a
relentless communications campaign
rallying resistance and calling in
foreign support
we have been saying this for a long time
that ukraine is seeking for protections
for our home soil and our own people but
such protections have not been provided
european countries assisted us with the
waves of migration however we should
discuss the guarantees that are required
to protect our country our home soil and
our people
a second round of talks on thursday
between russia and ukraine at a location
on the border with belarus came with low
expectations of a breakthrough but a
slim glimmer of hope that they're taking
place at all
[Music]
the ukrainian government meanwhile has
called for humanitarian corridors to be
set up and here in the western city of
volunteers are hard at work processing
aid donations medicines clothes food and
other essentials for distribution across
the country
there is a humanitarian crisis erupting
on multiple fronts not just the
internally displaced who've left
everything behind in a scramble for
safety across the country's borders as
more than a million have done since the
invasion began but also huge populations
in urban centers trapped terrified
and desperate for
help civilian morale will vary now in a
population increasingly terrorized
there'll be desperation in some places
determination in others
[Music]
a spontaneous rendition of the national
anthem at that aids station in uviv it
is becoming ever clearer that the
struggle is not just for personal
survival
but for the survival of the nation as a
whole
jonah al jazeera
[Music]
right let's discuss the military side of
things with pavel feldenhauer defense
and military analyst and columnist with
the russian newspaper navia gazetta with
us on skype from moscow thank you for
your time as always
i want to start by talking about
the convoy
the now infamous convoy we've got the
latest pictures of it which we're
running
40 miles long and apparently stalled not
going anywhere have you got any thoughts
on why that is why would this
huge military column just be sitting
there for four days
well i believe they're just simply stuck
in the mud so to speak
the
spring has come to these parts of
ukraine
uh the snow is melting and so they're
stuck to this uh
narrow
winding road and can't venture out into
the
fields uh and spread out because even
tanks get stuck in that money
interest
so they're they're in the pickle there
actually
so it's a kind it's a it's a traffic jam
on the
inside of the enemy nothing good there
of course ukrainians also can't go over
those fields because right now the
rasputits uh the uh spring
uh
has is coming
there's going to be more water in these
creeks and rivers the
there's going to be dirt uh the russian
it was a big mistake
for the russian military to go in so
late they should have done so not in the
end of february but most likely in the
end of january they wouldn't have run
into these problems
these problems are not so acute at all
in the south it's not it's a drier place
and but in the north uh this is very
seriously hampering the russian uh
offensive because you can't
go off roads and roads are bad in
ukraine they're narrow and there's not
many of them here it's not europe
okay that's in that respect okay that's
very interesting okay let's move on to
some other issues then and i think we
have to talk about this targeting of the
nuclear
power plant i said to our correspondent
earlier it is obvious that strategic
facilities like power plants would be
targeted but to actually fire on a
nuclear
facility is that not incredibly reckless
well no it's not just strategic
facilities it's specifically the nuclear
power plants of ukraine that have been
there been orders to take them over all
of them
and so russian troops are given orders
to take them over the ukrainians didn't
post any regular
army units
near these uh
power plant we're talking about
so specifically not to have a big battle
but the local population did offer some
resistance mostly peaceful not allowing
the russians in and they got desperate
and made and began firing shots so but
uh in moscow they believed that their
the power plants are a very big danger
and of course they are of any kind of
terrorist they believe attack by
ukrainian nationalists so to take them
under control all nuclear facilities
they began with the chernobyl
uh defunct uh uh uh former uh power
plant but also taking on the acting ones
but to go back to the point i made
you you're right taking over a power
plant sure i can understand that as as
as a tactic for russia but firing on it
it's a nuclear facility you don't what i
mean the the the risk for uh an accident
a terrible accident has got to be very
very high
it is
well but the troops were given orders uh
they hesitated then they were given
additional orders to go and do the job
and the russian soldiers they followed
orders uh apparently the fire was not at
the facility itself but the adjacent uh
training uh uh a building that didn't
really uh
so there this fire in itself did not
that much threaten the nuclear disaster
but yes this is a very dangerous thing
and the russian command commands given
to the russian soldiers are increasingly
ruthless to use blunt force
pavel falgenha uh defense and military
analyst thank you for your time we
appreciate it today
thank you